that's one of the things I I think that
is if there's a silver lining at all
that that's even to be said to come out
of this is that people are realizing you
have to take your security in your own
hands and your your own first responder
I can't tell you how many people I've
talked to also who have reached out and
said okay I'm gonna go get I'm gonna get
my first gun I need to know what to get
where to go and what kind of training to
get which is awesome to see and I think
what is it it's like an 80% increase
from this time last year in terms of the
number of people who have purchased guns
and a huge significant portion of that
is women because people are watching
what they're seeing on television and
they're watching you know you can see
peaceful protests during the day but
then the Sun sets and you have all the
skinny fat kids in there all their black
hot topic here that come out to burn
down buildings because that is protected
speech but disagreement is violence and
people see this joining me today is a
radio host television personality Second
Amendment advocate and author of grace
canceled Dana Loesch welcome to the
Rubin report I'd agree with you Dana
thanks for having me my pleasure
all right so just to clear it up because
it's gonna be weird in about ten minutes
we taped an hour-long interview about
three weeks ago in the midst of the
corona craziness and we were stocking
some interviews just because generally
things have been a little nutty and you
never know when you can get people but
before we release that I wanted to do a
quick 10-minute follow-up with you that
we're gonna post at the top of that
interview and separately as a clip just
to kind of get us up to speed on
everything that's happening with George
Floyd with the protests the riots racism
gun rights the whole thing so how's that
for an open-ended intro where do you
want to start with all of this oh my
gosh where I mean where - yeah where to
start
every it just feels like the world's on
fire kind of it does and and even though
it feels like there's there's a lot of
discussion and a lot of people who are
not listening everybody wants to be
heard and that's fine but I also feel
like there's no nuance and we can't have
any I feel like people are too afraid to
have honest
discussion honest I mean really I do I
feel like people are too afraid to have
an honest discussion because they don't
want to be cherry picked apart nuance is
dead and people are going to take the
absolute worst thing possible and they
are going to apply that and and
misinterpret anything that anyone says
so they can score a point and so real
genuine honest conversation cannot be
had we can't we can't even agree on what
the truth is anymore so I I mean I am
where do we go from here well listen if
only two people that were perhaps
talking right now had just released
books that in many ways deal with all of
these issues wouldn't that maybe have
perhaps possibly helped I think you are
onto something Dave I think you're onto
something that's a really good that's a
really good observation you're right
okay so let's let's start this way then
what I've seen is that it seems to me
that everybody across the political
spectrum almost with no exclusions is
completely disgusted by what happened to
George Floyd they want justice to be
served they want there to be a proper
investigation all of that and that there
could have been a moment where we could
have come together here and instead I
would say bad actors mostly an tyfa sort
of combined with black lives matter have
taken advantage and now we basically are
seeing our country and actually all over
the world cities that are on fire so to
sort of turn this to your specialty I'm
noticing that even here in the people's
banana republic of California in Los
Angeles that average people who never
would have thought about having a gun
are suddenly talking about getting
getting guns I have a couple friends
that just got guns this weekend you
can't get it immediately there's still
the 10-day waiting period but that went
to get guns this past weekend are you at
least enthused that people are gonna
take some of their security into their
own hands I am especially now that we're
being told that the police could be
defunded or demilitarized or however
they're trying to walk that back I mean
I that's one of the things I I think
that is if there's a silver lining at
all that that's even to be said to come
out of this is that people are realizing
you have to take your security and your
hands and your your own First Responder
I can't tell you how many people I've
talked to also who have reached out and
said okay I'm gonna go get I'm gonna get
my first gun I need to know what to get
and where to go and what kind of
training to get which is awesome to see
and I think what is it it's like an 80%
increase from this time last year in
terms of the number of people who have
purchased guns and a huge significant
portion of that is women because people
are watching what they're seeing on
television and they're watching you know
you can see peaceful protests during the
day but then the Sun sets and you have
all the skinny fat kids and they're all
they're black hot topic here that come
out to burn down buildings because that
is protected speech but disagreement is
violence and people see this I mean I've
been talking to business owners business
owners who who have have sacrificed so
much and they've been shut down for I
don't know how many like three months
now they barely made it through the
pandemic lockdown and now they have to
shut down again if there's going to be
riots in their area and they don't want
to have everything that they that they
work for destroyed and they're like okay
what do I do I need to be able to get a
fire I need to get a gun I need to get a
wonder I get a shotgun what do I've had
so many people ask me this and I'm glad
to see it I wish it wasn't under these
circumstances you know I wish that
people even during times of total safety
and security would realize that you know
this is this is a right that everyone
should be able to exercise no matter
where they are or what side of the
political aisle they fall on what do you
make of a meme that we're sort of seeing
out of the left these days that you sort
of reference there which is that words
are violence but apparently now violence
is in violence so we're hearing this all
over the place now that violence against
property is not violence I'm pretty sure
that if someone burned down your house
you might consider it a violent act am I
crazy dana loesch no you're not at all
I'm pretty sure if one of the people
saying that had their house the fact
that are their business affected and
burned down they probably changed their
mind on that real quick that is violence
that's a weird thing about it if you
have disagreed with an Tifa or the
far-left on anything disagreement itself
is so provocative that it's tantamount
to violence alone but if you engage in
the actual physical activity of violence
and whether you're assaulting people are
setting fire to something that's somehow
protected speech and by justifying
disagreeing speech and
presenting it as violence they're
finding they're just now fabricating
ways to justify their actual physical
violence they've they want to argue
themselves their way out of it and I
that's so dangerous I don't like speech
being portrayed as violence it's not
physical violence is violence speech
itself is is not violent it's not
anything but speech so I know we talked
about the the silver lining part of this
that people are thinking about their own
personal security and their family's
security and and that's good as a
conservative are you kind of surprised
that the wake up call to this was sort
of amorphous mobs coming to people's
property and businesses as opposed to
overreaching government right because
usually conservatives frame though oh
I've got to have a gun to keep
government away from my property but
this is to keep citizens we we thought
we had police that could do that now
we've got police kneeling in the streets
yeah no I think that's a good question I
think some of it too is I do think that
some political parties bears some
responsibility with us so in some regard
it is a little bit government but yeah
that isn't that kind of what the Second
Amendment has always been for it's that
uncomfortable aspect of it that everyone
whispers about while they all say that
it's really just it's only about hunting
and self-defense yes but also it's to
keep your government in check and that's
why we're so different from every other
country out there and with this you know
Antipa seems with all the expose is
going on about a antifa i mean they're
they're now classified as a terror group
they're sort of they act kind of like
this militant far left arm of the
Democrat Party I don't I can't see any
candidates being prevailed upon to
denounce their violence they soap for
soap it seems like they just kinda
pretend that they don't exist in fact I
think some of them had said oh no this
is just these are just like little local
groups it's not really an organized
national effort but it but it is yeah
but it is well you saw you saw Keith
Ellison's picture with the anti-fur book
from yeah a year ago right let's not
yeah since deleted it but this guy was
almost in charge of the DNC he lost by a
couple votes and he's the Attorney
General of what state and he said yeah
of Minnesota yeah and he's and he
supports and he supports an Tifa look
about what I guess it was about two
years ago I cut a short just commentary
about Antipa violence and this was at
the height whenever
was writing on college campuses and how
dare they bring in a conservative to
talk to anybody and they were setting
trash cans on fire and busting up
windows and I played footage of this
video and I was condemning the violence
and the far-left who engaged in it and
defended it turned around and said that
I was calling for violence by condemning
their violence because condemning their
violence by itself is a provocative act
and we're in an upside-down world right
now where we're wrong is right right is
wrong everything is awful cats and dogs
living together it's like that line that
Bill Murray has run out right now all
right so I got one more for you and then
we'll play the full hour interview for
the people that are like my my friends
that I talked about this weekend who are
getting guns for the first time what
what would you want them to know what
resources would you send them to for the
people that have just their whole lives
have been anti-gun or never thought ever
ever ever that they would have a gun in
the home that are now rethinking it
what's sort of the most what's the best
piece of advice you can give them as
they enter into this world they need to
get something that they feel comfortable
shooting first off and it also depends
on whether or not this is something that
they're gonna use for home defense or if
they're going to go get their concealed
carry license and if it's gonna be
something that they carry I have a lot
of different firearms for different
purposes whether it's you know my
bedside I hear something you know my
alarm goes off in the middle of the
night or if I'm wearing a cocktail dress
and I am going to an evening event you
know there's something else that you
know it's like shoes you know you got to
have you gotta have some variety but I
you know I always say you can't really
ever go wrong with a shotgun
you really can't if you don't have a
rifle if you've never you've never shot
a semi-automatic if you don't have a
handgun shotguns are always that's
always like a really good first choice
and the cool thing about gun owners is
that they are so incredibly helpful good
law-abiding gun owners all across the
country are so eager to share with you
what they have found works for them and
what doesn't what kind of training works
really well there's all kinds of like
you know you have the California rifle
and pistol Association out where you are
some really awesome people that do
really good training they're like
up-to-date with everything and they have
really
recommendations as well as to where you
can go what ranges you can go to I mean
we people even get it down to you know
ammo selections for crying out loud so
there's there's so many resources out
but I always tell people if you're not
you know if you if you've never been
around firearms
shotguns always something really good to
start with for handguns I like to
recommend like a Glock 19 which is
personal preference of mine you know six
our p3 65mph out there and a lot of
these a lot of the manufacturers out
there - these all started you know that
a lot of them are American companies
American manufactured American jobs and
that's one of the other focuses I think
of our issues today is keeping
everything right here in the US of A if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversation about the gun
debate instead of non-stop yelling check
out our gun debate playlist and if you
want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell